[Musique]
c'est la première fois que je vois un
petit homme c'est tellement minuscule
[Musique]
tag ira
pourquoi ne suis-je pas comme les autres
tu es unique petit frère l'un des bras
alors certains sont les gages de là tu
te vois pas te laisser marcher dessus
comme ça
lilou sa vie toujours ensemble sauf que
lui c'est par l'eau j'ai bien vu comment
tu regardes le village
mots-clés tuer des leurs
[Musique]
j'ai toujours rêvé appartenir à ce monde
tu seras toujours mon fils mots clés
rien ni personne ne pourra changer ça
les 33 de changer chaque jour l'homme la
colonie davantage le petit est sans
doute notre seul espoir de survie
nous avons peur de ce que l'homme peut
nous faire que tu as besoin de toi mots
clés
par exemple c'est fou comme tu as grandi
je ne suis pas un homme mais je ne suis
pas un mot non plus
lequel d'entre vous va me suivre
petit d'homme tout la jeune top 16
je refuse de perdre